what up Council my name is Chad Kroger
and I've never been more stoked to speak
to y'all aliens are real more aliens are
coming that's why I'm proposing that the
city of Los Angeles set up a welcome
party for our new green Buddies this
needs to be the ultimate rager we need
to have a DJ I think Zed would crush it
imagine aliens cruising in to Clarity
bumping on the speaks then for catering
I'm thinking Pedro's Tacos we've got to
support local Cuisine and small Biz what
up we gotta have a good ratio so maybe a
councilman you could fly in some Pro
volleyball players that'd be sick and
then we gotta be sponsored by dev's
liquor endless supply of vodka that's
Crush finally I think we need a surprise
appearance by Tom Delong from Blink-182
we owe that dude a massive apology sorry
Tom and uh everyone be chill too we
can't all be like who do you know here
we gotta treat these dudes like they
grew here not like they flew here